ah c'est
bon bien Mesdames et Messieurs mes chers
collègues bonjour à tous notre
délégation a confié à nos deux collègues
Anne Annemie Romanie pardon anneesophie
Romanie et Marion Canales une mission
flash sur la mise en uvre de la
directive CSRD qui vise à mieux encadrer
les rapports extra financiers des
entreprises alors qu'aujourd'hui en
Europe seul 11 600 sociétés sont tenus
de présenter un tel
rapport 50000 entreprises seront à terme
concerné il était important pour nous
d'apprécier l'impact de ces nouvelles
obligations un an jour après jour c'est
aujourd'hui le premier anniversaire
après la publication de cette directive
dont on entend beaucoup parler sur le
terrain c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous organisons ce matin deux tables
ronde en complément des travaux menés
par les rapporteurs et des documents de
travail que tous les sénateurs pourront
retrouver sur l'application démire à la
date d'aujourd'hui la première table
ronde porte un titre volontairement un
peu provocateur pour lancer le débat
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
arnaque ou àour en effet comme l'avait
mise en évidence les travaux de la
délégation sur le sujet la directive
CSRD s'inscrit dans la thématique plus
générale de la RSE dont il convient de
préciser la portée les enjeux nous
entendrons donc ce matin dans l'ordre
suivant madame Julie enciidi
responsable de l'engagement extrême en
Europe au sein du fond d'investissement
Black Rock
substainable en transition solution il
s'agit de la plus grande société
d'investissement et de gestion d'actifs
au monde qui gère près de 10000
milliards de dollars d'actifs vous
pourrez réagir madame sur les critiques
de ceux qui comme aux États-Unis
dénoncent le
capitalisme les performances mesurées
selon les critères ESG environnement
social gouvernance évalue impact positif
des entreprises sur la planète ou bien
ces indicateurs servent-ils simplement à
mesurer un risque
financier puis nous entendrons Madame
Michelle
papalardau présidente du comité de
réforme du label
ISR investissement social responsable
créé en 2016 et actuellement attribué à
1200 fonds gérant plus de 750 milliards
d'euros d'actifs madame vous pourrez
exposer les grandes lignes de la réforme
d'un label qui avait perdu en exigence
et en créd
selon les termes du rapport de
l'Inspection générale des
finances enfin interviendra Monsieur
Pierre
Victoria président de la plateforme RSE
de France stratégie qui réunit toutes
les parties prenantes de la
RSE monsieur Victoria vous pourrez
décrire l'impact des actions des acteurs
publics sur les pratiques de RSE le
développement de la commande publique
responsable et la mise en œuvre des
politiques publiques en accord avec des
objectifs de développement
durable je vous remercie tous trois de
votre présence aujourd'hui au Sénat je
vais tout d'abord vous céder à chacun la
parole pour un propos liminire que je
vous prierai de bien vouloir limiter à
on va dire 8 minutes afin de laisser le
maximum de temps d'échange qui devront
se terminer à 9h15 au plus tard puisque
pour que nous puissions passer à la
deème table ronde ensuite mes collègues
vous poseront leurs questions à commencé
par les rapporteurs de la mission donc
anne-esophie Romanie et Marion Canales
je rappelle que cette table ronde est
retransmise en direct et sera disponible
en vidéo à la demande sur le site
internet du
à vous donc la parole en commençant par
Madame ans
merci bonjour à tous merci monsieur le
Président approchz
le merci
beaucoup merci pour cette invitation à à
participer à ces discussions sur des
sujets importants donc je suis
effectivement en charge de l'engagement
externe au sein de Black Rock
sustainable and transition solution qui
est une une équipe globale d'environ 40
personnes aujourd'hui en en charge de
définir justement la stratégie de de
Black Rock sur ces enjeux de durabilité
je va surtout parler de durabilité mais
effectivement ça recoupe tout à fait les
les questions de responsabilité sociale
des entreprises et de mettre en œuvre
cette stratégie mais bien sûr avec un
grand nombre d'équipes aujourd'hui
impliqué au sein de BlackRock que ça
soit la recherche les produits les
risques et et un grand nombre d'autres
équipes encore une fois et notamment nos
investisseurs donc au total pour vous
donner une idée c'est aujourd'hui à peu
près 500 personnes qui travaillent sur
des sujets de durabilité et de climat en
particulier euh y compris des
scientifiques et des experts sectoriels
qui vraiment intègrent ces ces
préoccupation au sein de de leur métier
au quotidien peut-être un mot sur Black
Rock donc vous l'avez dit effectivement
plutôt 9 un peu plus de 9000 milliards
de dollars d'actif sous gestion
aujourd'hui investi sur toutes les
classes d'actifs donc action
obligation actifs monétaires et aussi
actif non côté on a des bureaux dans une
trentaine de pays euh et on sert des
clients de toutes toute nature
c'est-à-dire des clients particuliers
mais aussi des clients institutionnels
et tous avec des objectifs et des
horizons d'investissement
différents donc nous sommes gérons pour
compte de tiers c'est-à-dire que
l'argent que nous gérons n'est pas le
nôtre mais l'argent de celui que de de
des clients qui nous qui nous le
confient euh et beaucoup de ces clients
prennent leurs propres décision en
matière d'allocation d'actifs et de
construction de portefeuille notre rôle
pour tous ces clients c'est de
rechercher les meilleures performances
possibles en fonction de leur choix
d'investissement et de leur préférence
et bien sûr en gérant le mieux possible
les risques alors un mot sur Black Rock
en France aujourd'hui c'est à peu près
un peu plus de 200 employés 45 milliards
d'euros d'actifs sous gestion géré par
Black Rock pour des clients français et
puis 200 milliards à peu près d'euros
investis dans l'économie française pour
le compte de de clients globaux encore
une fois avec toute une large palette de
clients en France donc effectivement
responsabilité sociale arnaque ou atout
un titre un peu provocateur euh ce que
je vais essayer de faire très rapidement
c'est de de vous montrer comment ces
sujets sont abordés au sein de Black
Rock l'approche que que nous prenons et
effectivement en tant qu'investisseur
global aussi représenté dans dans toutes
les
régions mais peut-être un un mot pour
pour dire que la prise en compte de ces
enjeux de durabilité donc plus largement
de de responsabilité sociale et
environnementale des entreprises c'est
pas une mode ou une contrainte
réglementaire mais une tendance de fond
qui réflète à la fois une éution des
préférences des clients et de nos
investisseurs en particulier en Europe
mais aussi des transformations en
profondeur des modes de production et de
consommation donc notre rôle en tant
qu'investisseur c'est d'évaluer quelles
implications ces transformations peuvent
avoir au niveau macroéconomique en
particulier bien sûr le le la transition
versune économie bas carbone mais plus
largement au niveau des portefeuilles et
au niveau de chacune des entreprises
dans lesquelles nous investissons pour
le compte de NES clients donc c'est pas
à Black Rock de définir comment les
entreprises doivent appréhender leur
responsabilité sociale au sens large
mais bien sûr nous attendons qu'elles
expliquent euh comment elles prennent en
compte les risques et les opportunités
dans les domaines environnementaux et
sociaux comment ell les intègrent dans
leur stratégie et dans leurs opérations
comment elles gèent et répondre aux
impacts négatifs qu'elles peuvent
générer sur la société euh et et et
l'environnement et comment elle gère
aussi sur le long terme leur relation
avec les leurs parties prenantes de not
point de vue c'est effectivement comme
ça qu'une entreprise à plus de chances
de réussir sur le long terme et c'est
pour ça aussi que nous avons soutenu
depuis plusieurs années les efforts de
de transparence à la fois au niveau des
entreprises pour les encourager à à
volontairement lorsque le cadre
juridique n'était pas en
place rendre public un certain nombre
d'informations et les efforts des
régulateurs pour pour introduire cela
dans dans les obligations qui qui impose
qui s'impose aux entreprises à la fois
côté et non côté donc notre approche en
matière de durabilité
elle son elle est vraiment ancrée dans
ce qui fait le le le le mandat et le
rôle d'un d'un gérant d'actif c'est
notre responsabilité vis-à-vis des
clients qui nous confient leur argent et
donc cette approche de la durabilité
elle est ancrée sur trois piliers
indissociables le premier c'est
développer une gamme de stratégies et de
produits d'investissement qui répondent
le mieux aux besoins et aux préférences
de ces de ces clients notamment sur les
enjeux environnementaux et sociaux et
dans le domaine on voit que nos clients
ont des préférences qui peont êre très
varié qui peuvent aller effectivement de
l'exclusion ou la limitation de
l'exposition à certains secteurs jusqu'à
l'investissement à impact
positif mais qui reste encore une une
petite part de de ce qu'on fait le
deuxième piler encore de l'approche euh
de notre approche de la durabilité c'est
dans le cadre des des objectifs
d'investissement que que les clients
définissent leur rechercher pour eux les
meilleurs résultats à la fois en terme
de rendement euh de de de risque et euh
encore une fois d'objectifs qui sont
fixés éventuellement aussi d'objectifs
extrafinanciers et le trième pilier qui
est fondamental et qui a vraiment encré
dans dans l'histoire de Black Rock c'est
fonder notre approche d'investissement
sur la recherche et l'analyse des
données encore une fois pour être euh
délivré au mieux euh euh notre
responsabilité vis-à-vis des clients
donc encore pour illustrer la la
tendance de fond qu'on a qu'on a vu en
Europe mais plus largement dans le monde
aujourd'hui la plateforme
d'investissement durable donc des des
produits d'investissement et des
stratégies qui prennent en consid tion
ces enjeux c'est aujourd'hui 700
milliards de dollars d'actifs sous
gestion à peu près en
2023 à travers à peu près 500 produits
en 2020 c'était 100 milliards de dollars
chez Black Rock donc c'est une
croissance extrêmement rapide qui encore
une fois reflète aussi ce qu'on a vu
dans l'industrie mais plus largement
aussi une une une une vague que le que
Black Rock a a pris pour ses clients
donc on continue à étauer cette gamme
chaque année à la fois pour répondre au
au aux besoins qu'on voit se diversifier
de de nos clients à des nouvelles
méthodes et nouvelles approches données
qui sont disponibles un point aussi
important c'est qu'en 2023 dans des
conditions de marché difficiles on a
continuue à voir que ces produits
d'investissement notamment en Europe
surtout en Europe on continue à à à
attirer le les investisseurs et à
générer des flux d'investissement
positifs ce qui est pour nous vraiment
le signe d'une tendance beaucoup plus à
long terme de de l'intérêt des
investisseurs sur ces produit qui
prennent en considération encore une
fois des degrés variés ces
considérations environnementales et
sociales
sur le climat qui est vraiment le ce que
ce qui nous a concentré le plus et qui a
concentré beaucoup bien sûr aussi
l'attention des
entreprises un nombre vraiment très
important nos clients institutionnels en
particulier en Europe mais c'est aussi
vrai dans le monde aujourd'hui pris des
engagements climat que ça soit à travers
des coalitions d'investisseurs comme la
net Z0 à honur alliance ou bien des des
engagement pris à titre de manière
indépendante donc aujourd'hui dans les
discussions que nous avons avec ses
clients institutionnels il cherchent à
comprendre comment mettre en œuvre ses
engagements par exemple par des
objectifs de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre lié à leur
portefeuille d'investissement ou à
aligner ces portefeuilles vers une
trajectoire par exemple net zéro mais on
voit aussi une une autre demande des
clients qui est de comment investir dans
la transition on a réalisé cet été une
enquête auprès de 200 investisseurs
institutionnels les plus importants dans
le monde entier et cette demande très
forte d'investir ou de d'accroître
l'exposition à la transition euh
s'exprime sur toutes les régions euh à
plus de 56 % de de de nos investisseurs
institutionnels qui répondent ça avec
même une petite une sur représentation
des investisseurs d'Amérique du Nord ce
qui ce qui est important à noter aussi
et pour l'ensemble de ces de ces 200
investisseurs institutionnel il
considèrent la transition comme une
priorité encore une fois compris du
point de vue de la gestion des risques
ou de la recherche d'opportunités ou
encore une fois pour mettre en œuvre des
engagements donc deux deux initiatives
très vitees cette année sur sur la
transition qui a faliser nos nos efforts
d'une part la recherche on a publié cet
été la un transition scénario qui est la
vue la plus plausible à date que l'on
considère enfin ce que l'on considère
peut être le rythme et la forme que veut
prendre la transition dans les années à
venir et ça c'est indispensable en tant
que investisseur en prenant en compte à
la fois comment les politiques publiques
pourraient avancer les évolutions
technologiques et les préférences des
investisseurs le deuxième effort
significatif qu'on a fait c'est de
développer une et de définir une
plateforme d'investissement pour la
transition encore une fois pour les
clients qui souhaitent investir dans la
transition cette plateforme aujourd'hui
elle représente environ 110 milliards de
dollars d'actifs sous gestion c'est pas
exactement
riqué dans la plateforme
d'investissement durable que j'ai
mentionné tout à l'heure parce qu'on
peut avoir des
solutions des stratégies ou des produits
d'investissement sur la transition qui
ne passe pas forcément encore la barre
des critères qu'on a définis pour les
produits d'investissement durable euh
donc voilà j'en arrête là sur notre
approche de la durabilité les défis vous
en avez mentionné certains monsieur le
Président notamment la polarisation
extrême qu'on a vu aux États-Unis sur
ces sur ces sujets mais qu' et puis et
puis le fait que les transitions dont on
parle j'ai parlé de la transition
climatique principalement mais d'autres
transitions restent incertaines et
complexes donc c'est des c'est dans
cette contexte que nous nous situons et
je suis à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions merci encore
merci Madame madame papa
lardau merci monsieur le Président
bonjour à
tous ben merci de me donner l'occasion
de de présenter le le résultat
finalement de la refonde du label
puisque vous êtes en pleine actualité le
le texte a été publié mardi matin donc
vous êtes dans les premiers auquels je
fais cette présentation je rappelle
simplement donc ce label date de 2016
donc juste après la COP 2015 il était
innovant à l'époque hein puisque c'était
les les les premiers les premiers pas de
l'application des des de l'article de
l'accord de Paris qui disait que la
finance devait
participer à la transition d'une manière
générale la transition écologique et et
à la transition énergétique et donc il
reposait beaucoup sur des principes de
transparence puisque c'était le début
donc l'idée c'était d'accompagner les
entreprises dans leur démarche de RSE et
et dans la donc la mise sur le sur en
public de de tout ce qu'ils essayaient
de faire à l'époque c'est un un label
qui porte sur les fonds hein je précise
bien j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure alors
en 2020 vous l'avez rappelé également
rapidement dans votre introduction le
ministre de chargé des finances puisque
le label est rattaché sous la tutelle du
ministre des Finances a demandé un
rapport à à l'IGF qui a conclu que
effectivement le le label était devenu
moins moins innovant et surtout pas
assez
exigeant et donc c'est le le le le
fondement du travail qui nous a été
demandé donc au comité du label ISR de
faire une refonte du référentiel du
label je rappelle aussi avant de
préciser ce qu'on a fait que c'est un
label généraliste hein ce n'est pas un
label vert c'est pas un label qui a pour
vocation de faire avancer
essentiellement sur la dimension
environnementale c'est bien un label
ESG qui qui vise à avoir à soutenir les
entreprises qui ont ces démarches
générales qui peuvent être bien entendu
très très vertes mais qui peuvent être
aussi très
sociales c'est tout à fait possible on
peut avoir des fonds qui sont très peu
concernés par le le le climat par
exemple mais qui sont des labels qui
sont labellisés ESG donc il y a souvent
un petit malentendu sur ce point-là
parce que une partie de la critique
porte effectivement sur le fait que le
le label était pas assez vert mais ça
n'est pas le le son fondement son
fondement c'est d'être généraliste h et
puis avec à l'origine donc cet objectif
de transparence alors ce qu'on a fait
dans le cadre de la réforme donc ça fait
2 ans qu'on travaille sur l'évolution du
du label c'est d'essayer de le rendre
plus exigeant et et de passer d'objectif
de transparence des objectifs de
résultats et et donc progressivement de
d'avancer bien entendu vers des des des
des spécificités beaucoup plus précises
que ce qu'on avait dans le label à
l'origine c'est pas le label précédent
c'est toujours le même label mais c'est
le label de l'origine alors sur trois
points particuliers nous nous faisons
porter nos nos évolution d'abord avoir
un label plus sélectif c'est-à-dire que
les les fonds qui sont labellisés
aujourd'hui jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui
devait exclure disons les les entre ises
les moins bien noté les 20 %
d'entreprises les moins bien notées à
partir de du nouveau référentiel c'est
30 % des entreprises des moins bien noté
ça c'est un objectif simple quand on dit
exigence c'est ça on est plus sélectif
bien sûr il y a beaucoup d'autres choses
derrière ce ce ce ce ce ce cette ce
qualificatif de de sélectif il y a d'une
manière générale on a précisé beaucoup
d'éléments qui dans le label précédent
étit voilà évoqué on va dire mais pas
précisé ce qui disait que les
certificateurs pouvaient pas s'appuyer
sur sur ces éléments pour dire bah non
vous pouvez pas être labellisé donc là
aujourd'hui les choses sont sont précise
je vous donne juste un exemple aussi
chiffré c'est plus facile sur les les
les droits de vote bon ben référentiel
précédent disait qu'il fallait voter aux
assemblées générales d'accord mais on
nait pas d'objectif bien précis à
mesurer là aujourd'hui on a bien
préciser que il fallait voter dans 90 %
des âgés pour les entreprises françaises
et dans minimum bien bien entendu 70 %
des âgés des entreprises qui ne sont pas
françaises donc voilà c'est pour que
vous compreniez bien ce qu'on a essayé
de faire sur tous les sujets et c'est ça
qui va qui va beaucoup augmenter
l'exigence
eu 2è 2uxè thème important c'est de de
d'avoir intégré la double matérialité
alors à l'époque en 2015-26 le sujet
n'existait pas donc on peut pas
critiquer le label pour le pas l'avoir
fait nous en tout cas on voulait que
clairement ce soit fait dans cette
version du du label d'une manière
générale d'ailleurs on a essayé de
s'appuyer et d'utiliser le plus possible
les texte européens alors c'est un peu
compliqué parce que les textes européens
bougent même donc on va on va se courir
un petit peu après les uns les autres
mais c'est nécessaire que on appuie la
mise en œuvre des textes européens et
puis qu'on fasse évoluer j'y reviendrai
le label quand les textes mêmes auront
changé donc double matérialité ce qui
signifie qu'on on on
demande on demande et et là on revient
sur la transparence en fait on demande
au fond de d'expliciter de dire quels
sont les incidenence négatives des
entreprises qui sont dans le fond
puisqueaujourd'hui c'est la meilleure
chose qu'il puisse faire donc ce qui
veut dire qu'au fur à mesure que les
entreprises vont exprimer ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui avec les textes
européens le des pai c'est-à-dire leurs
indicateurs d'incidence négative et bien
les fonds les rendront publes les
communiqueront bon c'est un premier pas
vous voyez bien dans un premier pas on
fait de la transparence dans un second
pas bien entendu on mettra des des des
obligations et des exigences en terme de
résultats il y a quand même déjà une
obligation de une exigence de résultat
sur ce thème-là c'est que le les les
fonds qui sont labélisés doivent
désigner deux indicateurs sur lesquels
ils doivent être meilleurs que le le
périmètre leur univers de de départ et
on exige que sur ces deux indicateurs il
y en a un qui soit un indicateur de P
d'incidence négative donc déjà on les on
les contraint un peu dans dans en terme
de de résultat sur ces éléments là et le
la troisième point important dont on a
beaucoup parlé c'est de mettre le climat
comme un unons un élément incontournable
d'une démarche ESG c'est pas l'objectif
de la démarche g parce que pour certains
certaines entreprises et certains fonds
c'est pas ça leur objectif leur objectif
c'est plus d'être dans du social par
exemple mais en tout cas ils doivent
tous se préoccuper de la dimension
climat et dire ce qu'ils font sur la
dimension climat donc on le voit à
travers bien entendu les les les
incidences négatives et cetera mais
surtout ça nous a conduit donc à
procéder à des exclusion ce qui
n'existait pas dans le référentiel
précédent nous n'avions pas d'exclusion
là on a fait des exclusions alors on a
fait des exclusions sur les trois
domaines e s et G les exclusions sur le
S et les exclusions sur le G sont assez
classiques et vont probablement pas
provoquer beaucoup de d'évolutions le ce
qui a fait parler c'est les exclusions
dans le domaine de l'énergie ce qui
n'est pas non plus le seul sujet qui
nous intéresse en matière de
d'environnement on est bien d'accord
mais l'exclusion elle porte sur
aujourd'hui sur l'énergie et donc on a
exclu les énergies fossiles au sens du
charbon des fossiles non conventionnel
et de tous les nouveaux projets qui
soient conventionnels ou non
conventionnel en en matière d'
hrocarbure on en a beaucoup parlé ça
n'aura pas forcément un impact
extrêmement important sur la
labellisation au non des fonds
puisque le aujourd'hui même s'il y avait
pas d'exclusion même si le sujet était
pas au cœur du référentiel on a que 1 %
de la capitalisation de nos fonds qui
pent sur ces sujets d'énergie fossile
donc pas non plus en faire
une un élément extrêmement structurant
de ce qui va se passer après mais c'est
clair au moins c'est clair c'est affiché
et et c'est partagé et et cont tenu de
ce qui s'est dit à la à la à la COP ces
derniers jours c'est important autre
sujet important sur le climat c'est les
plans de transition alors là aussi on
innove un peu puisque Ben bien entendu
ça n'existait pas en 2016 et qu'on est
encore un peu balbutiant sur ce que sont
ce que c'est qu'un plan de transition
donc on a essayé de définir ce que
c'estc un plan de transition c'est pas
seulement une trajectoire en 2050 hein
c'est un ensemble de de cible pour
arriver à à l'objectif 2050 ou ultérieur
c'est aussi des moyens et c'est aussi
une gouvernance ça veut dire que c'est
il faut que ce soit crédible et bien sûr
que ces plans de transition soi
compatible avec l'accord de Paris alors
nous nous avons là aussi une démarche en
deux temps d'abord une démarche de
transparence c'est-à-dire qu'on va
demander à toutes les entreprises enfin
au fond demander à leurs entreprises de
de dire ce qu'ils font en matière de
transition et on va demander à partir du
prier 1 janvier 2026 à ce que au minimum
15 % des entreprises des secteurs à fort
enjeu c'est-à-dire les secteurs qui sont
vraiment très impliqués et qui ont des
conséquences importantes sur le sur le
changement climatique c'est ce sont des
définitions qui sont dans la sfdr dans
la réglementation européenne nous on a
inventé aucun indicateur et aucune
définition donc on prend les définitions
de la sfdr donc ces secteurs à fort en
jeu qui représentent à peu près la
moitié de
l'économie vont pour 15 % des des des
fonds devoir montrer qu'ils ont un plan
de transition compatible avec l'accord
de Paris au 1er janvier 2026 et pour 20
% en plus ils doivent s'engager à avoir
ce ce plan de transition dans les 3 ans
qui viendront euh donc c'est un début on
sera probablement beaucoup plus exigeant
au cours des des années qui viennent au
fur à mesure que bah les entreprises se
seront emparées de ce ce sujet des plans
de transition voilà les les grandes les
les les les
grandes axes en fait de de cette de
cette refonte je rappelle simplement et
je je je j'insiste sur le fait que
l'intérêt du label c'est de labelliser
des fonds mais en labellisant des fonds
on a bien sûr un impact sur les
entreprises puisque les fonds ce qu'on
leur demande c'est de vérifier que leurs
entreprises dans lesquelles les
investissent ont progressé dans leur
démarche ESG et ce qu'on leur propose
c'est à travers le fait du label donc
d'une certification on est bien d'accord
il y a un tiers qui vérifie que le label
est appliqué de de de d'avoir finalement
une reconnaissance de la démarche ESG
des des fonds et donc forcément des
entreprises qui sont à l'intérieur merci
beaucoup merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur Victoria on vous écoute
monsieur prés monsieur le Président
Mesdames les rapporteurs et
M excusez-moi j'ai la voix un peu
couverte aujourd'hui mesdames et
messieurs monsieurs les sénateurs merci
de votre invitation donc je suis le
président effectivement de la plateforme
RSE alors vous connaissez sans doute un
peu la plateforme RSE puisque vous n
avez largement cité dans le rapportex
rapport que vous avez fait sur la
question de la RSE don la plateforme RSE
a été créé il y a 10 ans après par le le
dans le gouvernement de Monsieur
Jean-Marc erud après le et et et après
oui après l'effondrement du Rana Plaza
c'est-à-dire cet effondrement vous
souvenez au bangladesch qui a quand même
fait 1300 morts le rappeler et qui a
posé avec beaucoup d'acuité la question
de la chaîne de responsabilité ou la
nécessité d'allonger en tous les cas la
question de la responsabilité des
entreprises vis-à-vis de leur chaîne de
sous-traitance l'idée de la plateforme a
été très simple c'était de réunir à un
moment donné des acteurs qui ne se
parlaient pas ou qui se parlaient mal
les entreprises les syndicats les
organisations de la société civile les
chercheurs et les institutions publiques
pour les faire travailler ensemble sur
l'ensemble des questions liées à la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
en ayant comme définition de la RS qui
était en gros l'ISO 26000 on va pas
revenir mais qui elle mérite de d'être
longue elle mérite de dire tout et et
sans doute l'inconvénient d'être d'être
un peu longue
50 organisations ont été nommées par le
gouvernement donc cette plateforme RSE
est directement rattachée à la première
ministre nous sommes hébergés par France
stratégie qui nous apporte à la fois les
moyens humains et financiers permet
temps de faire notre travail notre
travail d'expertise de concertation et
de proposition donc c'est ça le le le le
rôle et la mission de la plateforme cinq
collèges un collège des acteurs
économiques des syndicats des euh des
organisations de la société civile des
chercheurs ce qu'on appelle chercheurs
et développeurs c'est ça intègre aussi
les S tank et des institutions publi je
suis moi-même issu du pôle chercheur et
développeur n'étant ni chercheur et pas
beaucoup de développeurs d'ailleurs mais
parce que le Comité 21 dont j'étais
vice-président était était membre de ce
de ce de ce de la plateforme et m'a
demandé de le représenter pour être vous
j'étais auparavant directeur du
développement durable du Groupe volia
pendant une quinzaine d'années et j'ai
également été administrateur salarié
c'est-à-dire élu par les salariés pour
représenter les salariés au sein de
cette
entreprise le l'intérêt de la plateforme
c'est pas seulement le résultat du du
travail que l'on fait puisque alors nous
émettons depuis 10 ans on a émis 30
rapports la moitié à la demande du
gouvernement la moitié en auto cisine à
partir d'une feuille de route tri de 3
ans ou 4 ans que nous élaborons nous
venons de finir notre feuille de route
2023 et nous travaillons actuellement
sur l'élaboration de la la la feuille de
route 2024- 2027 ce qui est très
intéressant parce qu'on voit que les
sujets de la RSE bouge évolue de façon
considérable donc nous essayons de
percevoir aussi la nature des tendance
actuelle de voir les manques qu'il y a
en matière d'expertise et de travail à
partir de là on définit notre propre
feuille de route alors les derniers
travaux que nous avons fait les les de
alors nous faisons en gros quatre
rapports par an c'est qu' pendant fait
un rapport 6 mois de groupes de travail
qui se réunissent pendant 6 mois et qui
dans lequel se retrouent bien évidemment
les représentants de chacun des pôles
c'estàd que c'est vraiment le pôle qui
structure l'ensemble du fonctionnement
de la plateforme c'est chaque pôle
désigne des représentants soit qui sont
des memb soit au sein des des différents
acteurs des personnes plus qualifiées
pour assurer les expertises nous faisons
des expertises nous faisons des
recommandations donc le pôle l'pôle est
un élément clé le bureau est un élément
de décision et qui et surtout qui veille
à ce que le le périmètre des études soit
bien celui qui est conforme à la feuille
de route qui a été adopté et les 50
membres se retrouvent par ailleurs en
assemblée plinière trois fois par an
pour valider notamment les
recommandations que nous faisons à
travers nos rapports donc les derniers
rapports pardon les deux derniers
rapports que nous avons fait et celui
sur l'impact et la responsabilité et
performance pluriel nous sommes
interrogés donc pour savoir si est-ce
que le concept d'impact était la
nouvelle frontière de la RSE qu'est-ce
qu'il disait à la RSE en quoi il
modifiait la RSE on pourra y revenir si
vous voulez dans le cadre du débat nous
avons fait le dernier rapport qui vient
d'être présenté il y a 3 semaines c'est
sur le rôle des acteurs publics en
matière de RSE c'est qu'un premier
travail puisque au départ sur la
question des acteurs publics il y avait
trois grandes problématiques euh que
auquel nous souhaitions euh sur lequel
nous souhaitions travailler qui était la
commande publique c'est comment le le
l'ensemble des des fonction publique
hein d'État territorial et hospitalière
peuvent être des acteurs de la
transition et intégrer les questions de
RSE dans leur propre appel d'offre dans
un contexte européen qui qui n'est pas
toujours simple on souhaita également
travailler sur les questions de la
conditionnalité des aides et aussi de du
rôle de l'État actionnaire sur lequel il
me semble qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à
faire pour intégrer les problématiques
sociales et environnementales dans la
stratégie donc ça c'est c'est le
derniers rapport que nous avons fait ce
qui deux ou trois rapports que je
voudrais alors actuellement on finit un
rapport surd RSE qui va paraître au
début de
janvier-février et euh et qui va être
notre et et d'autre part nous commençons
un travail fait par la qui comme demandé
par la délégation inter ministériel au
réfugiés de travailler sur les questions
d'intégration des réfugiés dans le tissu
économique français voilà qui va être
donc les des rapports sur lequel auquel
nous nous attelons
aujourd'hui ce qui est essentiel de
comprendre sur notre travail c'est que
nos propositions nos propositions
doivent être nécessairement être
consensuelles c'estàdire ce que nous
recherchons c'est vraiment le fait qu'il
y a un vrai dialogue et de concertation
qu'on sorte des positions convenues pour
être en situation de pouvoir faire des
propositions qui soit conjointe aux CIN
pôles structurantes de de de la
plateforme et je le dis avec insistance
d'abord parce que j'ai je l'ai découvert
moi-même parce que je n'étais pas à la
plateforme il y a il y a 2 ans donc j'ai
découvert cette capacité à à dialoguer à
discuter à se concerter et à faire des
propositions entre des acteurs qui comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure ne sont pas
toujours tendres les uns avec les autres
et on a vu notamment sur le devoir de
vigilance et c'est sans doute un atout
qui est insuffisamment reconnu dans le
travail de la plateforme toute façon on
on souvre d'une certaine manque de
connaissance de la réalité du travail
alors certes nos travaux sont dans le
domaine public et chacun peut y appr
prendre ce qui est bon à y prendre vous
même vous l'avez fait dans votre rapport
sur la délégation permanente on a vu
dernièrement que sur un enfin
dernièrement l'été dernier que sur un
rapport sur le travail des provs qu'on
avait fait sur les salariés aidents
dernier dossier que sur lequel le
gouvernement n av demandé de travailler
avait été repris dans le projet de loi
gouvernemental par contre on a aucun un
retour on n pas de système qui nous
permett de dire que les recommandations
que l'on fait que ça soit les
recommandations elles s'adressent pas
qu'au pouvoir public s'adress
essentiellement au pouvoir public bien
évidemment au secteur professionnel voir
voir aux différents acteurs membres de
la plateforme on manque terriblement de
retour sur la réalité des propositions
que que que nous sommes amenés à faire
donc voilà ce qui ce qui la plateforme
plateforme RSE alors notre je répondrai
pas à la question at tout ou ou enfin
j'ai la réponse d'ailleurs si vous
voulez mais je pas le temps de sans
doute de le
développer ce qui enfin on s on s'est
par contre beaucoup posé la question de
savoir si le thème RSE était encore le
plus perpinant dans le monde de la
durabilité qui s'ouvre devant nous
notamment d'ailleurs la mise en œuvre de
toute la la problématique européenne et
de la construction européenne d'une
d'une de la durabilité des entreprises
entre Green Deal taxonomie devoir de
vigil européen et d sur lequel vous avez
à travailler beaucoup nous avons dit que
RSE était un terme à la papa qui ne
répondait pas au différentes évolutions
c'est-à-dire un que le question
aujourd'hui qui a été posé depuis 10 ans
c'est quand même depuis 10 ans ou 15 ans
enfin notamment depuis les objectifs du
développement durable et et l'accord de
Paris sur le climat qui est la question
de l'utilité sociétale de l'entreprise
en quoi vous êtes utile à la société et
en quoi vous participez quelque part à
la problématique des biens communs donc
il y a ceux qui se disent que il faut
plus parler de responsabilité
mais mais d'utilité il y a le mouvement
sur l'impact et vous pouvez retrouver
dans notre rapport notre vision sur
l'impact en disant est-ce que l'impact
c'est la nouvelle frontière la réponse
pour nous est non c'està-dire que c'est
un outil énorme la mesure de l'impact et
notamment il faut le remettre dans le
casre de la CSRD et notamment dans le
casadre de la double matérialité pour
faire en sorte que justement les
entreprises ne puissent pas être taxé de
de de de enfin la question de la
responsabilité de l'entreprise reste
questionnée par l'ensemble de la la
société donc la mesure de la Pact c'est
bien une façon d'évaluer de montrer la
réalité du du travail qui a été fait et
et pourtant et donc on était assez
ouvert d'ailleurs à ce type de réflexion
mais il nous semble que les dernierses
années que nous avons vécu c'est-à-dire
entre la question du covid la question
de la guerre en Ukraine sur lequel nous
avons fait une proposition nous avons
fait un texte sur à l'égard des
entreprises qui étaient présentes
notamment en Russie mais pas que sur
l'ensemble de la question la
géopolitique et de la RSE il nous semble
que la question donc on a vu là que la
question de la responsabilité était
posée on l'a vu aussi d'ailleurs sur la
question de l'inflation enfin il nous
semble que le terme de responsabilité ne
peut pas être
complètement fondu dans l'idée ni de
l'impact et de la durabilité qu'elle
reste extrêmement pertinente dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui face justement aux
différentes crises auxquelles nous
sommes amenés à à à agir et que sur
lequel les les les acteurs économiques
doivent assurer leur leur propre leur
propre responsabilité je vrais juste
finir en disant que bien évidemment
notre vision de l'entreprise c'est
l'ensemble des entreprise c'est-à-dire
que on ne travaille pas
seulement pour les 300 grandes
entreprises françaises ni pour les je
pres chiffres parce que les plus de 5000
entreprises à taille intermédiaire ou
les et les 138000 PME notre vision n'est
pas de trouver d'être dans une logique
seulement de de travailler avec les
entreprises les plus engagées c'est
vraiment de faire en sorte que
l'ensemble de la question sociale et
environnementale soit prise en compte
par l'ensemble du tissu économique ce
qui nous amène à nous adresser à tous
les secteurs économiques dans leur
ensemble mais aussi au liens qui les
unissent parce que nous pensons que les
relations entre grandes entreprises ETI
PME notamment dans une vision
territoriale doivent être revu et
amélioré voilà l'esprit dans lequel nous
travaillons de la
plateforme merci monsieur le Président
merci mesdames pour vos propos liminires
je vais dorén avant laisser la parole à
nos deux rapporteur et et ensuite nos
collègues pourront poser des questions
merci merci beaucoup pour ses
présentations anne-esophie Romanie je
suis sénateur de la
Marne et nouvelle sénatrice puisque je
suis arrivée en septembre aux dernières
élections 2 2
octobre j'aurais effectivement quelques
questions madame Sid à vous poser en
2020 vous vous engagez à respecter les
critères ESG dans vos investissements
mais en 2023 vous semblez avoir renoncé
à cette exigence pourquoi une telle
évolution et ma deuxième question sera
comment considérez-vous la double
matérialité en dehors de l'Europe la
matérialité simple domine la CSRD
est-elle un atout ou un handicap pour
les entreprises
européennes et moi je vais peut-être
compléter pour vous poser donc Marion
canalet je suis sénatrice du puits de
Dôme euh et nouvellement élu également
euh l'objectif de ma question c'est de
savoir s'il est possible si vous pouvez
investir en Europe en prenant en
considération les critères ESG ce que
vous ne pourriez pas faire dans certains
états des États-Unis comme par exemple
le Texas le Texas qui proscrivent ce
qu'on appelle le capitalisme
W voilà merci beaucoup mesdames les
sénatrices euh
alors je peut-être ces deux questions
sont sont liées avec la la première que
vous vous me posiez sur la position de
Black Rock sur les les enjeux
ESG et l'évolution de la situation aux
États-Unis qu'on qu'on a vu avec une
polarisation des des débats c'est
effectivement une polarisation des
débats aux États-Unis et non pas
seulement une approche uniforme aux
États-Unis d'un rejet antiw ou anti
antiesg et donc pour Black Rock c'est
vrai que ces derniers mois ces dernières
années il a été important de de rétablir
de clarifier l'approche de de de Black
Rock vis-à-vis des des parfois
représentation erronées de l'action de
Black Rock de replacer notre approche de
la duréhabilité encore une fois dans la
responsabilité que l'on que l'on a
vis-à-vis de nos clients mais ce qui ne
veut pas dire que notre approche de la
durabilité a changé au cours de ces
dernières années c'est-à-dire que encore
une fois c'est la responsabilité de
l'investisseur de considérer ces
facteurs environnementaux et sociaux
parce que ils sont ils peuvent avoir des
impacts encore une fois sur la
performance à long terme euh des
entreprises et parce que aussi ce sont
des euh encore une fois des des éléments
que nous considérons euh lorsque nous
interrgissons avec nos clients et que
nous considérons euh leurs préférences
euh pour pour ces sujets vis-à-vis de
ces sujets environnementaux euh et
sociaux en ce qui concerne donc en ce
qui concerne le les comment les
initiatives qui ont été pris au Texas et
dans d'autres États européens
effectivement ça s'est traduit par Black
Rock qui qui est apparu sur des des
listes euh de boycotte dans ces États
européens encore une dans ces États
américains pardon mais encore une fois
ça n'affecte pas l'approche queon a de
la durabilité et et la façon dont on
considère les entreprises dans le monde
entier et la façon dont on développe
aussi nos produits d'investissement la
recherche et l'intégration des des
considérations ESG qui par ailleurs est
une obligation en Europe donc on a un
comment une une intégration document
public qui détaille cette façon dont on
intègre ces con considération dans nos
stratégies d'investissement et cette
considération des facteurs e s et G
varie en fonction des stratégies
d'investissement notamment lorsqu'il
s'agit de de gestion indicielle par
rapport à une gestion active et en
fonction de de chaque objectif des fonds
mais c'est quelque chose que que l'on
fait de manière indépendamment en fait
des objectifs du fond mais ça se ça se
décline de façon différente et de la
même façon dans la façon dans dans
engager avec les entreprises de voter
aux assemblées générales ça fait
plusieurs années que les thématiques
environnementales nature droits humains
droits social font partie des
thématiques bien sûr gouvernance depuis
de aussi comme priorité font partie des
thèmes avec lesquels on engage les
entreprises et pour lesquels on est
amené à se positionner dans les
assemblées générale en ce qui concerne
peut-être la CSRD à tout handicap et et
plus généralement les et les questions
de double matérialité euh je pense que
un des atouts euh pour les entreprises
qui
s'engagent dans ce mouvement de de
reporting et on le voit en France
puisque les les obligations qui POS
pesaient sur les entreprises françaises
certes côtés était sont bien antérieurs
à à ce que connaissaient d'autres pays
européens je pense que c'est un atout de
ce point de vue par rapport à d'autres
entreprises dans le monde qui vont
arrivriver plus tard dans ce processus
de de de reporting obligatoire et euh on
voit déjà aussi volontaire puisque le le
mouvement notamment sur le climat de de
de transparence des entreprises sur la
façon dont elles répondre aux enjeux
climat augmente donc de ce point de vue
je pense que le plus tôt les entreprises
peuvent se préparer aujourd'hui ça
devient la loi en Europe c'est important
la prise en considération de la double
matérialité elle s'inscrit encore une
fois je crois que Monsieur Victoria le
mentionnait la CSRD c'est un des
éléments d'un cadre beaucoup plus large
en Europe beaucoup plus ambitieux et qui
a touché à la fois le secteur financier
et les entreprises mais aussi des des
initiatives sectorielles notamment dans
le domaine climatique et
environnemental et par ailleurs les les
investisseurs sont aussi soumis à des
obligations de reporting de sur les
impacts positifs et négatif de leur de
leurs investissements donc on va bien
sûr euh s'inscrire dans ce mouvement en
tant qu'investisseur présent en Europe
et et qui soumis déjà aux obligations de
la sfdr donc l'obligation qui passèe sur
les gérants et les et les fonds
d'investis isement mais effectiv mais
en en considérant les préférences des
clients et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui ces
préoccupations sont prises à des degrés
exprimé à des degrés divers dans les
préférences des investisseurs parfois ça
se traduit
par des des des des exclusions ou bien
euh une intégration dans un vue de
performance à long terme les
investisseurs qui aujourd'hui
recherchent des impacts positifs à
travers les investissements on envoie
nous-même on développe des produits on a
une plateforme d'investissement à impact
mais ça reste encore une une partie
assez faible de nos
portefeuille merci
euh nous aurions aussi alors on va poser
l'ensemble des questions pardon à tout
le monde euh je t'en prie vas-y Mario
pardon euh alors oui pour micro pardon
concernant concernant ant le comité du
label yr madame la Présidente
pouvez-vous préciser nous préciser le
lien entre le règlement sfdr qui
s'adresse aux investisseurs financiers
et la
directive CSRD et puis je vais laisser
poser une question à les questions de ma
collègue et je reviendrai peut-être en
complément à à tout ça euh vous avez
exprimé l'exclusion de des énergies
fossiles mais vous nous avez pas
expliqué ce qui avait finalement pesé
pour leur exclusion donc moi c'était
plutôt cette question là même si vous
nous disiez que ça ne pesait finalement
pas grand-chose sur l'ensemble des
entreprises mais qu'est-ce qui fait que
finalement ces énergies fossiles ont été
exclus et je voulais savoir également ce
que vous pensiez des critiques porté sur
la double matérialité par Emmanuel
Fabert au nom de
l'issb et puis et puis du du coup si je
si je peux compléter
sur ont des énergies fossiles comment
est-ce que les fonds ont réagi à cette
exclusion et puis ensuite pour Monsieur
Victoria la voix d'une économie
responsable de l'Europe est encore seule
à assumer cette façon de de faire
est-elle l'unique façon de conjuguer
durabilité et compétitivité et comment
rester compétitif si l'Europe est la
seule à proposer ses exigences c'est une
une question importante et euh j'aurais
souhaité savoir s'il était possible
d'avoir une vue exhaustive sur
l'ensemble des impacts d'une entreprise
sur l'environnement est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui existe et que vous
savez euh définir quant à moi j'aurais
bien voulu ça que vous nous précisiez
euh les difficultés pour les TPE et les
PME de la mesure d'impact d'une
entreprise sur l'environnement de
manière pratico-pratique puisque c'est
évoqué dans dans le le rapport de la
plateforme RS en février 2023 et que les
entreprises voil font face à des
difficultés extrêmement pratiopratiqu et
que vous en avez les contours en tête
merci merci pour ces questions on va
essayer quand même de tenir dans les
délais donc je vais être brve
forcément pour répondre à à ces
questions qui sont assez larges voilà
c'est ça pour pour la sfdr la CSRD je
vous l'ai déjà un peu dit en fait nous
pour pour nous c'était évident qu'il
fallait qu'on qu'on suive et qu'on
intègre bien entendu ces
réglementations européennes dans la
nouvelle version du référentiel d'autant
que on a commencé à travailler au moment
où la SF la sfrd la SF c'est compliqué
c'est la SFD euh est sorti et que donc
on a commencé à voir des fonds qui se
classaient en article 8 article 9 on m'a
même dit à ce moment-là mais finalement
pourquoi vous faites un label ISR
puisqu'on a alors je je j'insiste sur le
fait que il y a une différence
fondamentale c'est que d'un côté on a
des réglementations qui sont en
évolution ce qui est normal parce qu'on
va très vite sur des sujets très
compliqués et que donc c'est en marchant
que finalement on on finalise les
définitions les bons les bons textes et
cetera je je reconnais que c'est
extrêmement compliqué pour les sociétés
de gestion qui sont concerné hein ou par
les pour les entreprises socié gestion
pour la CFDR et et les entreprises pour
la CSRD c'est clair mais bon voilà on en
est tous là et on essaie tous d'avancer
d'avancer le plus vite possible parce
qu'on a pris un peu de retard donc on a
intégré le plus possible les définitions
comme je le disais nous n'avons inventé
aucune définition aucun indicateur dans
le nouveau référentiel et ben on
l'adaptera au fur à mesure que les
choses changeront aussi dans les textes
européens bien entendu l'idée c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'on a vécu cette
fois-ci on fasse pas une refonte du du
label tous les 9 ans mais qu'on y
revienne tous les 2 ans 2 ans et demi je
pense que c'est vraiment le le le bon
tempo pour que on soit toujours dans
dans la dans l'actualité je j'allais
dire réglementaire donc voilà pour nous
c'est c'est clairement comme ça que les
choses doivent se faire o on se suit ça
met un peu d'instabilité dans le paysage
je le reconnais mais voilà c'est là
c'est c'est la conséquence du fait qu'on
essaie d'avancer plus vite sur la la
question de et donc on est très content
d'avoir ces deux textes et notamment euh
la CSRD parce que c'est parce que la
CSRD existe et a fait avancer un certain
nombre de choses que nous nous pouvons
demander au fond de demander aux
entreprises un certain nombre
d'informations alors on est un peu en
avance c'est normal le label il doit
toujours être en avance par rapport à la
réglementation sinon c'est pas un label
donc il doit être en avance donc il
incite les entreprises à aller un peu
plus vite que simplement respecter les
textes mais c'est quand même dans le
cadre des textes pour pas que les les
uns et les autres soient se dispersent
en fait sur des demandes variées il y a
suffisamment de choses dans les reportin
qui sont demandé aujourd'hui dans les
dans ces deux textes vous m'avez ensuite
posé une question sur mais pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez fait des exclusions
et en particulier les exclusions des
fossiles je pourrais vous faire une
réponse simple c'était parce que c'était
écrit dans le rapport de l'IGF mais ça
n'est pas pour ça que nous l'avons fait
en tout cas c'est pour ça qu'on s'est
posé la question le le on y a vraiment
réfléchi beaucoup je on sait que a
priori enfin je j'ai dit assez
clairement au début que moi j'étais pas
absolument convaincu qu'il faille faire
des exclusions parce que je considère
que le label est là pour accompagner et
pas pour forcément exclure mais il nous
est apparu clairement au bout de de de
quelques mois de discussion que
aujourd'hui pour un épargnant qui
cherche à ou un investisseur mais disons
pardon plus plus plus largement encore
qui va vers une
démarche de durabilité et qui veut
investir dans des entreprises qui sont
dans cette dans cette démarche il a
forcément en tête
une une dimension climat importante elle
est aujourd'hui incontournable c'est le
le terme que j'ai que j'ai utilisé et
c'est vraiment ça qu'on a en tête on
peut pas faire aujourd'hui ça aurait dû
être le cas plutôt mais ENF aujourd'hui
c'est le cas dire qu'on fait de de de de
la RSE sans s préoccuper de sa dimension
climat et dans cette préoccupation de
dimension climat quand on le voit à au
niveau de des des fonds globalement le
le le le fait d'investir ou non dans des
énergies fossiles et on n' pas exclu
toutes les énergies fossiles puisque le
conventionnel euh en stock on va dire
c'est celui qui n'est pas en train de
faire de nouveaux de nouveaux projets il
est pas exclu en tant que tel mais il
doit avoir un plan de transition voilà
et c'est là qu'on accompagne la démarche
de ceux qui sont dans le fossile
aujourd'hui on sait bien qu'on a quand
même encore un peu besoin de fossile
pendant quelques temps malheureusement
on doit ils ne peuvent venir dans dans
les fonds labellisés que s'ils ont un
plan de transition compatible bien sûr
avec l'accord de Paris c'est ça le la
logique en fait de de de de la démarche
qui que l'on a que l'on a pris mais
comme je vous le disais ce qu'on
constate finalement c'est que même si il
y avait pas d'exclusion dans le
référentiel précédent et qu'on disait
absolument rien sur les différents types
d'activités en particul en particulier
sur les fossiles de même les les fonds
allaient sur les entreprises qui
n'étaient pas dans les énergies fossiles
puisque au total on a que 1 % de de
capitalisation donc c'est pour ça que
c'est je je je j'insiste un peu
là-dessus parce que c'est souvent la
critique qui a été fait au référenciel
ISR c'était que on nexcluait pas
suffisamment et cetera alors qu'en fait
et c'est très bien les fonds et les
entreprises qui allaient dans cette
direction elle le faisait d'elle-même et
c'est c'est ça le label c'est c'est
d'encourager à avoir une démarche ESG et
que chacun cherche où est sa démarche g
dernier point alors là je vais aller
très vite sur la double matérialité et
Monsieur Fabert bon je veux pas rentrer
dans un débat avec Monsieur Fabert moi
ce que je considère c'est que pour un
épargnant qui va dans un fond
ESG pour lui il se pose pas la question
de double matérialité ou pas parce que
de toute façon il sait pas ce que c'est
mais moi je je je ne conçois pas qu'il
qu'il qu'il aille dans ses fonds en en
ayant en tête que l'on ne tienne pas
compte de l'impact des entreprises qui
sont dans ces fonds sur l'environnement
sur le social ou sur la gouvernance
c'est forcément ça qu'il attend il
attend pas de savoir si dans les fonds
on a bien tenu compte de la conséquence
financière parce qu'en fait c'était ça
la première la première matérialité
qu'on avait jusqu'à présent c'est-à-dire
on était censé mesurer être sûr qu'on
avait bien tenu compte des conséquences
de l'environnement du social et de la
gouvernance sur le fond c'est important
on est d'accord mais forcément quand
vous investissez avec cette volonté
d'aller de soutenir d'une démarche AG
vous vous intéressez à l'autre
matérialité celle qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui celle qui fait la double
matérialité donc pour moi en tout cas
pour le label ça me paraît évident qu'il
faut aller dans cette direction là je
pense que d'une manière générale si on
veut faire de l'ESG il faut aller dans
cette directionl après si on veut pas
faire de VG on fait autre
chose je vais peut-être rebondir
d'ailleurs sur le sur la partie la
partie européenne enfin la plateforme a
fait un rapport il y a 3 ans 3 ans et
demi justement sur la question de
comment se positionner par rapport à aux
dynamiques européennes structurant et
quelles étaient les conséquences en fait
pour pour l'économie française la la
réponse qui a été unanime c'est de dire
que on s'inscrivait totalement dans une
vision de l'entreprise
qui doit assurer une plus grande utilité
sociétale ou améliorer sa relation avec
la société que c'est ça dans le fond le
modèle européen d'entreprise
c'est-à-dire que oui il existe quelque
part un modèle européen d'entreprise qui
intègre les questions de la société et
la participation de l'entreprise que ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure au au au
bien commun donc on a on a très
clairement pris position en faveur de la
politique européenne et notamment en
faveur de de des travaux de l'ffrag à ce
moment-là d'ailleurs c'est aussi ce que
vous dites vous-même dans votre rapport
on a trouvé des des convergences
d'opinion et on est
persuadé d'une part que c'est ça le sens
de l'histoire c'est qu'une aucune
activité économique comme était dit
pendant le débat ne peut perdurer si
elle n'est pas en résonance avec les
attentes de son époque donc il y a pas
d'entreprise qui durera et qui sera
durable si elle ne répond pas aux
attentes de son époque et que la
politique européenne nous semble aller
dans son esprit dans dans ce sens-là et
que nous devons y être non seulement
présents moteur et vigilant aussi sur
les conséquences effectivement de ce qui
peut s passer je reviens pas sur sur ce
qui a été dit la deuxième chose aussi
que ce qu'on s'est dit sur la politique
européenne et qui renvoie à la question
de la double matérialité on on est
toujours un peu interrogatif au sein de
la plateforme et on le dit d'ailleurs
dans le rapport sur l'impact sur où en
est l'évaluation l'évaluation justement
de la loi pacte
française dont on trouve que
l'évaluation n'est pas à la hauteur en
tous les cas des érence que le rapport
senénar nota avait pu laisser entendre
dans la relation entre l'entreprise et
la société mais aussi dans la
convergence d'acteurs différents pour
porter cette cette vision sociétale et
notamment sur la question de l'article
1233 du Code civil c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui quand on parle de la loi PAC
on parle de la raison d'être on parle
des sociétés à mission mais on parle pas
de ce qui étaé fondamental c'est-à-dire
l'obligation depuis 2019 pour tous les
entreprises d'être géré en en prenant en
considération les enjeux
environnementaux et sociaux donc la
notre vision et notre adhésion quelque
part problématique européenne est aussi
une façon de de de faire appliquer le le
l'attention du législateur pour prendre
en compte cette modification de
l'article 133 du Code civil et et c'est
aussi pour ça d'ailleurs que nous sommes
favorables et on l'a dit au concept de
double matérialité je reviens pas ce que
Madame papalard dit mais derrière il y a
vraiment une vision de la relation
entreprise et la société qui n'est pas
la même aujourd'hui nous semble-t-il
dans le monde anglo-saxon mais nos amis
de Black Rock le diront mieux que moi
que sur la vision européenne sur la
question des des PME qui qui est
cruciale pour nous parce que les PME
sont sans doute une des acteurs
économiques les plus dynamiques conc la
plateforme RSE ce je dis et d'ailleurs
je je je me permet de vous renvoyer sur
un un rapport que j'ai là sur la table
qui s'appelle label RSE proposition pour
des labels RSE sectoriels destiné au au
TPE au PME et aux ETI qui est un
excellent rapport qui explique pourquoi
à notre avis il faut aller vers des des
labels sectoriels pour les PME parce que
c'est un élément clé de la
reconnaissance de celles qui font des
efforts en matière
environnementtal et sociale et que si on
ne fait pas ça quelque part on va
désespérer un peu les efforts qui sont
faits depuis ces dernières années en
matière des PME ce qui a Mme à à
répondre aussi à V question sur la CSRD
c'est-à-dire on est très attentif à ce
que l'application de la CSRD à partir de
2026 aux entreprises de moins 250
salariés puisse se passer dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
c'est-à-dire que je je le dis on l'a vu
dans nos rapports que il y a une
dynamique aussi de PME pour prendre en
considération les enjeux
environnementaux et sociaux il faudrait
pas qu'une douleur technocratique qu'un
excès de demande
d'information puisse casser dans le fond
alors deux choses puisse casser quelque
part les dynamiques en cours disant si
voilà soit la marginaliser parce que le
le risque de la CSRD c'est que on
refasse du
reporting pour faire du reporting mais
sans du tout l'intégrer à la stratégie
des entreprises j'ai j'ai voilà et c'est
ça le sujet c'est c'est pour ça que le
le le le le chapeau loi Pact est
important pour nous parce qu' il porte
une vision de la relation entreprise et
la société et de faire en sorte que ça
soit pas uniquement des indicateurs ou
des réponses à des indicateurs précis
que l'on fasse dans un bout de table
dans un coin qui nintéresserait personne
et que ça soit vraiment la question de
la la de la prise en compte des enjeux
environnementaux sociaux et leur
évaluation et leur comparaison qui soit
pris en compte en tous les cas il faut
aider les PME à et veiller à ce que la
France obtienne aussiteun européenne que
les les que les les normes qui leur Soi
appliqués soi à la fois simple
compréhensible et n'exige pas des moyens
humains et financiers complètement
déconsidéré par rapport à la réalité de
de l'entité économique qui
représente
merci monsieur le Président le le
libéral que je suis ne peut s'empêcher
une réflexion j'espère que dans tout
cela on n'oubliera pas que la priorité
des entreprises c'est ce qu'on leur
demande c'est de produire de la richesse
de l'emploi et de la valeur mais j'ai
bien compris au fait de vos nuances à
tous les trois que vous y accordez une
priorité aussi Michel canev pour une
question merci Monsieur sénateur du
Finisterre merci monsieur le Président
merci à nos intervenants puisque vous
venez d'évoquer la loi PCT don j'étais
le rapporteur sur cette partie ici au
Sénat et puisque nous sommes au
Parlement il est intéressant
effectivement notamment dans la
perspective de pacte de qui a été
annoncé par le ministre de l'économie et
des finances peut-être de voir s'il faut
aller plus loin nous avions eu le débat
à l'époque et c'était assez compliqué
pour voir comment introduire
effectivement les recommandations du
rapport nota
euh et président de Renault je sén c'est
ça tout à fait donc sur l'article 1833
vous pensez qu'on n pas allé assz loin
en ayant introduit la société gérée dans
son intérêt social en prenant en
considération les enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux de son Act activité
l'article 1833 est quand même assez
clair donc est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut aller encore plus loin c'est une
première première observation et puis la
la deuxième c'est que effectivement
comme vient de l'évoquer le président à
l'instant nous notre préoccupation ici
aussi c'est de faire en sorte que la
charge administrative qui incombe aux
entreprises ne soit pas pénalisante dans
l'exercice de leur activité en
particulier pour ce qui concerne les
entreprises de ta modeste comment
peut-on arriver à euh poursuivre des
objectifs de responsabilité sociétal et
environnemental et éviter que cela ne se
traduise par un carcan administratif qui
vise finalement à décourager
l'entrepreneuriat dans notre
pays avec une notion de
compétitivité je voudrais pas je n'ai
pas dit qu'il fallait modifier l'article
233 du Code civil j'ai dit qu'il fallait
évaluer comment il s'était mis en place
que les documents y compris ce nos amis
de France stratégie quand on parle de de
de l'évaluation de la loi Pact on ne
parle que on dit simplement qu'il y a 80
% des entreprises du CAC40 qui ont pris
une raison d'être 60 % de SBF120 je
crois que c'est à peu près ça les
chiffres et qu'il y a 1300 entreprises
qui ont pris la qualité de société à
mission mais ça dit pas si vous voulez
en quoi l'ensemble du tissu économique a
pris en compte les sujets
environnementaux et sociaux donc c'est
la question d'évaluation qui se pose de
ce qui était me semble-il le socle
puisqueen fait on est sur un triangle au
socle il y a l'article 833 puis les
raisons d'être puis la société à mission
mais on inverse un petit peu la la
pyramide on focalise sur sur ce qui est
plus facile à quantifiable on va quelque
part enfin c'est toujour la même chose
c'est un peu le syndrome du lampadaire
quoi c'est-à-dire qu'on va là où il y a
de la lumière et on parle de là où il y
a de la lumière mais on regarde pas
toujours l'essentiel du du sujet c'est
un peu ça notre la question qu'on se
pose et et on se demandait mais c'est
vraiment une question sur lequel on n'
pas répondu au sein de la plateforme si
la double matérialité ne pouvait pas
justement
permettre cela et sur le deuxème
point sur la question des des
indicateurs nous notre vision c'est
qu'il faut à la fois avoir peu
d'indicateurs mais par contre faut avoir
des indicateurs assez larges des sujets
de RSE c'est on ne peut pas le sujet du
climat est prioritaire et important et
les son ont dit mais c'est pas que ça
c'est pas que ça la question de de de la
respons ité territoriale et la
solidarité territoriale entre les
acteurs nous sommes un sujet majeur en
matière de RSE la question de
l'inclusion social aussi dans les
territoires la question de l'économie
circulaire c'est que il faut à la fois
faire simple dans les indicateurs et
embrasser un champ qui ne soit pas
uniquement réductible au sujet du climat
c'est peut-être des points
d'interrogation que nous pouvons
avoir sur ce second sujet de la charge
administra
bon d'abord c'est bien qu'on en soit
tous conscient parce que c'était pas
forcément toujours le cas doncon y soit
attentif les évolutions de la CSRD avec
l'idée de de centrer le reporting sur
les points sur les qui ont une vraie
matérialité un vrai sens en fait pour
les entreprises vont dans ce sens-là
l'inconvénient c'est que ben on va
perdre en information et en visibilité
globale on va voir comment l'équilibre
se fait mais c'est déjà la démarche qui
est euh qui qui qui est en en cours on
va voir comment les les chos
fonctionnent je suis complètement
d'accord avec ce que ve dire monsieur
Victoria il faut pas non plus être trop
réducteur parce que si on est trop
réducteur bah on on laisse de côté en
fait beaucoup beaucoup de monde et le le
le choix vous me posez la question de
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a exclu et
bah voilà la solution simple qui évite
d' avoir du reporting c'est dire bah on
exclut ça ça ça et ça voilà on fait une
grande liste et puis c'est facile
euh bon et puis il y a l'autre solution
qui est de dire on va déjà essayer de
comprendre où vous en êtes et donc
l'intérêt du reporting bon c'est vrai
que c'est une charge administrative mais
il faut que ça ait un sens en fait pour
moi le vrai sujet c'est ça il faut que
ça ait un sens pour l'entreprise donc il
faut que ça corresponde à sa démarche et
à sa stratégie et qu' en fasse quelque
chose l'intérêt du label je
réfléchissais c'est que ça ça donne un
intérêt à son reporting c'est que si
vous voulez être dans un fond qui est
labellisé il faut l'avoir fait et et
avoir utilisé les résultats pas juste
avoir fait des des tableaux et mis des
chiffres et puis on les envoie et ça va
rentrer quelque part dans un dans une
grande matrice de données qui va être
utile on est d'accord mais ça va pas
vous même suffire à à vous faire vous
mobiliser pour le reporting donc il faut
que ce reporting il ait un sens vraiment
donc qu'il soit pas exubérant et
extravagant il faut leaitdire
systématiquement et l'avoir bien en tête
mais il faut qu'il ait un sens pour
l'entreprise il y a comme ça que
vraiment on va on intègre ce ce cette
démarche dans le fonctionnement même des
entreprises quel que soit leur taille
non peut-être juste un mot pour
compléter du point de vue de
l'investisseur donc aussi à charge pour
nous nous de nous organiser pour
absorber et utiliser ces nouveaux
reporting sous une forme qui reste à à
voir on va voir les premiers les
premiers rapports et quelle forme ils
vont avoir il y a beaucoup de
qualitatifs aussi dans ces rapports qui
sont indispensables je pense enfin on a
on a longtemps pour des quelques
indicateurs notamment sectoriels
lorsqu'ils sont sur des sujets variés
d'ailleurs de la RSE mais aussi la la
effectivement l'information qualitative
est importante pour comprendre comment
l'entreprise s'empare de ces indicateurs
puisquelle commence par mesurer mais ça
permet de définir sa stratégie et et et
encore une fois comment l'investisseur
peut ensuite en tirer des des
conséquences dans dans la démarche
d'investissement sur en général pour un
investisseur global nous nous on on a
été on est bien sûr vigilant aussi sur
l'interopérabilité c'est-à-dire que ça
soit aussi facile pour les entreprises
qui vont devoir réorter dans d'autres
régions de pouvoir utiliser ce qu'elles
font en Europe bien sûr qui est plus
exigeant euh et puis peut-être sur la
question des PME et en général il y a il
y a quand même beaucoup d'indicateurs
sur le climat ça ça ça a progressé très
vite mais il y a des indicateurs dont
les méthodologies sont encore difficiles
hein bien sûr la nature en particulier
c'est c'est des sujets euh sur lequel
collectivement les entreprises les
investisseurs on s'est pas encore bien
mesuré je crois que c'était une des
questions évoquées euh ces ces questions
donc euh on on dans dans notre réponse
notamment au au au législateurs
européens c'est effectivement de pouvoir
accompagner cette
euh collectivement comment est-ce qu'on
on on progresse dans dans les outils de
mesure et sur les PME je pense que c'est
pareil aussi un peu de de de de
proportionnalité de laisser le temps
mais je pense que c'est pas que la
contrainte réglementaire aussi qui vont
forcer les les PME à s'adapter c'est
effectivement leur chaîne de valeur qui
vont le demander des informations les
investisseurs et et nous on a une
réflexion aujourd'hui dans les
stratégies d'investissement encore une
fois dans le non côté donc avec des PME
des ETI et comment aussi l'investisseur
peut accompagner ses premiers pas
parfois des entreprises dans dans dans
un reporting et la définition d'une
stratégie notamment sur les sujets
climat merci on aurait une question de
notre collègue la dernière question de
notre collègue blen en lui demandant il
nous reste vraiment 2 3 minutes parce
que faud qu'on teste aussi la technique
après parce qu'on a une partie en visio
donc le plus concis possible et bien
évidemment je vous demanderai également
dans les réponses d'essayer de faire y
blven donc sénateur du morbillan tout
nouveau sénateur du morbillan je vous
écoute avec beaucoup d'intérêt sur la
mise en place de ces labels sur la
responsabilité sociétale de l'entreprise
l'entreprise citoyenne et cetera et
cetera on a vu il y a déjà une vingtaine
d'années arriver les norm ISO 9000
ceci et cela dans dans nos entreprises
moi je j'ai passé beaucoup de temps dans
le monde agroalimentaire on s'est tous
engouffré dans ce système pensant qu'on
allait vraiment mener des politiques de
différenciation et pouvoir se
différencier avec nos concurrents et
pendant ce temps-là on a vu débouler bon
au moment de l'agrandissement de
l'Europe des produits venants d'autres
partenaires européens sur lesquel il y
avait aucun respect des normes aucune
respect et on avait franchement
l'impression de se mettre des boulets au
et de courir moins vite que nos
concurrents vous n'avez pas l'impression
que là on pourrait aussi mettre autant
d'énergie que ce qu'on met sur les
labels et sur la certification des
entreprises sur leur démarche
citoyennes sur les contrôles on nous
parle de clause miroir on nous parle de
ceci et de cela mais quels sont les
moyens qu'on met en œuvre ne serait-ce
qu'à l'échelle de l'Europe pour faire en
sorte que on puisse tous courir avec les
mêmes conditions et les mêmes
contraintes parce que sinon on va se
s'alourdir euh les les les comment le
prix de revien euh bêtement alors que
d'autres vont le vont pas le faire et
puis juste rappeler aussi ce qu'on vient
de vivre depuis 2 ans c'est l'inflation
et le juge du consommateur qui arbitre
essentiellement sur des notions de prix
et que cette notion de comparer du label
quand il est dans le rayon vous savez il
regarde premier prix marque distributeur
point terminé et tous les labels de
qualité malheureusement sont en chute
vertigineuse faut aussi se rappeler ces
éléments
là je juste rappeler que nous
malheureusement peut-être ça se voit pas
dans le rayon on est d'accord hein c'est
c'est vraiment la belle de fond et donc
pas un label de produit même pas un
label d'entreprise non plus d'ailleurs
mais je comprends très bien ce que vous
dites et et je je rebondis sur le sujet
contrôle parce que je suis une grande
fervante aussi de de de cette idée de de
de fixer des résultats et et des
objectifs de résultats et donc d'avoir
des moyens de contrôle plutôt que de se
fixer des objectifs de moyens qui nous
contraignent ça effectivement mais sur
lesquels ensuite derrière on n' pas le
contrôle nécessaire pour faire la
différence B en ce qui concerne le le le
label ISR il s'applique à tous les
entreprises françaises ou pas hein qui
veulent être dans des fonds labellisés
donc une une entreprise non française
euh et même non ne européenne d'ailleurs
qui veut être dans des fonds labellisés
SR sachant que dans les textes
aujourd'hui il faut des fonds labellisés
à SR pour un certain nombre de de de
d'outils et notamment par exemple dans
les les les les Assurance Retraite et
les les les et cetera donc on on a une
pression pour que toutes les entreprises
aillent vers du label ISR euh vers des
oui des investissements qui soient dans
des labels ISR quel que soit leur
origine et il y a bien un contrôle
puisque il y a une certification tous
les 3 ans renouvelé tous les ans pour
vérifier qu'il y a pas de d'écart entre
la stratégie de la labellisation et la
réalité des faits donc on est bien dans
un processus en tout cas là de
certification par un tiers et donc de
vérification appliqué à tout types
d'acteurs merci euh merci euh mesdames
et monessieurs pour bah vos propos de ce
matin et votre présence d'avoir pu vous
rendre disponible vos analyses seront
précieuses je pense pour le travail de
nosorteur de nos reporteurs et
rapporteurs pardon qui sont aussi
quelquefois des
reporteurs et dans la rédaction de leur
rapport merci beaucoup et nous nous
allons passer à la deuxème table ronde
merci